i think we're going to go to liz cheney
let's dip in and see what you need
especially wonderful to be here
on the beautiful mead ranch uh and thank
you so much brad and kate for that
wonderful introduction
um we really are in god's country and
it's wonderful to welcome so many here i
want to say first of all a special
thanks to every member of team cheney
who is here in the audience
[Applause]
and to tell you our work is far from
over
uh
[Applause]
among the many many blessings that we
have as americans uh and and as
individuals and as human beings
the blessing of family is surely
the most important and so i want to
thank uh all of my family and pay a
special tribute to uh those who are here
with us tonight uh my mom and dad
dick and linchini
and my husband phil
[Applause]
and four of our five kids are here
katie and gracie and philip and richard
are all here tonight
and
elizabeth is starting law school today
so we'll have another generation
carrying on dedication to the
constitution and and to our freedom
a little over a year ago
i received a note from a gold star
father
he said to me standing up for truth
honors all who gave all
and i have thought of his words every
single day since then
i've thought of them because they are a
reminder of how we must all conduct
ourselves we must conduct ourselves in a
way that is worthy of the men and women
who wear the uniform of this nation
and in particular of those who have
given the ultimate sacrifice
this
this is not a game
every one of us must be committed to the
eternal defense of this miraculous
experiment called america
and at the heart of our democratic
process our elections
they are the foundational principle of
our constitution
two years ago i won this primary with 73
percent of the vote
i could easily have done the same again
the path was clear
but it would have required that i go
along with president trump's lie about
the 2020 election
it would have required that i enable his
ongoing efforts to unravel our
democratic system and attack the
foundations of our republic
that was a path i could not and would
not take
[Applause]
no
no house seat
no office in this land is more important
than the principles that we are all
sworn to protect
and i well understood the potential
political consequences of abiding by my
duty
our republic relies upon the good will
of all candidates for office
to accept honorably the outcome of
elections
and tonight harriet hageman has received
the most votes in this primary she won
i called her to concede the race
this primary election is over
but now
the real work begins
[Applause]
the great and original champion of our
party abraham lincoln was defeated in
elections for the senate and the house
before he won the most important
election of all
lincoln ultimately prevailed he saved
our union and he defined our obligation
as americans for all of history speaking
at gettysburg of the great task
remaining before us lincoln said
that we here highly resolve that these
dead shall not have died in vain that
this nation under god shall have a new
birth of freedom and that government of
the people by the people and for the
people shall not perish from this earth
as we meet here tonight that remains our
greatest and most important task
most of world history is a story of
violent conflict of servitude and
suffering
most people in most places have not
lived in freedom
our american freedom is a providential
departure from history we are the
exception
we have been given the gift of freedom
by god and our founding fathers
it has been said that the long arc of
history bends toward justice and freedom
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else